[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in rodney harrison who
hopefully will be in the hall of fame
one of these days two-time super bowl
champ and an analyst on football night
in america all right rod when you
you drop that bomb and i almost text you
to say are you an nfl insider now
uh you must have felt pretty strongly
about aaron
saying that to say that on super bowl
sunday
yeah when i had a chance to speak with
aaron we spent about 15 or 20 minutes
and you know i asked him i was like how
many more years you want to play you're
at eight and i'm thinking hey man you're
gonna play another extra you know
another seven years to get at least 15
and he looked at me and he was like hey
i tell my teammates all the time but
they don't believe me that if i win this
super bowl because how i prepare and the
way how hard i work on my body year
round and obviously you know he's
mentioned his family
like he's accomplished everything so
it's very believable he said hey there's
you know there's a chance that i can
walk away
and um i was stunned because i'm
thinking this guy has another seven
eight nine years and these guys are
different dan think about these young
guys they make so much money in a short
period of time they don't have to play
12 15 years like you know like old guys
like me i played 15 years i knew i could
still play but i wanted to continue to
make that extra money and these these
guys they make so much money especially
a guy like him he's coming off a 100
million dollar contract
you think that he's going to come back
and play
you know what right now i i saw him at
the parade and it was emotional let's
run it back there's a lot of emotional
type things you know before you you know
before you initially win that super bowl
your mind is playing tricks on you after
you win the super bowl your mind is
playing tricks i think you know i i
would like to see him come back and play
um because once you walk away there's no
there's no coming back you know what i
mean and you don't want to sit at home
and wish you could have done this could
have done that but he's got plenty of
time this offseason we'll see what
happens is there a better defensive
player
that you've seen
in history
i i you know what
i used to say i used to say um lawrence
taylor
then i was really really high on j.j
watt when he was at the top of his
career you know being defensive player
of the year over and over again but when
i saw aaron donald i just saw something
different i saw a guy that i could
connect with a guy that i just
absolutely fell in love with with how
hard he plays the game how tough how
passionate he is and you think about the
thing that game really changed the
course of the game was that melee on the
sideline when he pushed
burro on us and everybody it didn't just
spark him but a sean robinson he got
pumped up von miller like that's the
type of stuff that aaron donald does his
his passion his aggressiveness it's it's
infectious to his entire team dan
uh if if the rams could afford to lose
one player
or aaron donald or sean mcvay coach or
aaron donald if you if you had to lose
one
let's just say hypothetical you know
that sean went into the broadcast booth
or that aaron was considering retiring
if you had to lose one you lose the
coach
[Laughter]
you lose that coach because at the end
of the day dad as much as i like sean
mcvay he ain't out there you know
causing disruption taking on double and
triple teams and chips and things like
that he's not doing any of that he's
sitting back reaping the benefits of
having the greatest
player of all time what was matthew
stafford's reputation before sunday
he was tough but a guy that was always
limited because
of where he played and you know i i
respected him from afar never thought
that he was going to be a world champion
never thought he would get this
opportunity and you know i hear a lot of
people screaming and yelling hall of
fame hall of fame and i'm not not quite
yet man you still got you know some work
that you got to put in before we start
talking hall of fame with matthew
stafford
how what did you think of the bengals
approach to the rams offense after obj
went out
the bengals approached
yeah defensively
well i i just felt like um
i felt like the rams really struggled
once odell cause i had mentioned before
i made my pick i picked the rams and i
said oh i said odell beckham he could be
super bowl mvp if he wins that match up
against eli apple and it looked like he
was on his way a couple big catches a
touchdown um catch and before before you
know it he gets hurt then matthew
stafford saw cooper cup getting double
teamed and he's trying to figure out
okay let me go to van jefferson let me
go to van jefferson and he just couldn't
get it done with van jefferson so once
odell got taken out he got hurt it
really changed the course of the game
and then at the end you saw matthew
stafford say screw and i'm just going to
force the ball to cooper cup yeah i love
how people go well cooper cup's got to
be mvp because uh he was double teamed
and i said uh aaron donald's double
teamed every time
everybody yeah in the first half you
know cooper cups not doubled in the
first half it was when obj went out and
they're like uh we can double this guy i
just still don't understand how eli
apple is on cooper cup at the goal line
single cover it let me tell you
something it is amazing and the
defensive coordinator um lou anarumo
he told me before he said hey eli's
gotta before the game he said the most
important matchup is eli apple has to
match up be able to match up with odell
and there's no way i'm taking
my second or third corner and putting
them on cooper cup on the goal line in
the most critical moments of the game
and that's why i talk about um you know
like coaches man you got to have a feel
like that's eli apple against cooper cub
double team him yeah you can't let
cooper cup have that one-on-one matchup
it's crazy
well reminded me and i hate to bring it
up
ellis hobbs on plexigo burst where i
just went
the super bowl is over
like you know ellis is what 5 11 and
plexico is 6'5 and he's out there by
himself and the giant eli had to look
over there and go we just won the super
bowl
five he's even worse than that he's like
five nine against a guy that was six
five and you're looking like why are we
calling this play you like okay but and
you try to check it and you know what
happened happened
do you think tom is uh truly retired
brady
i would like to see tom just stay the
heck away from the game what more does
he have to prove 22 years man all those
let me tell you dan the thing that you
miss out on you miss out on being able
to go to your your kids recitals at 11
o'clock on a wednesday that stuff is
important man to be able to sit there in
the audience and watch your daughter
like i've been blessed enough and
fortunate enough where i don't miss any
football games i go to all the
volleyball games i go to all the
recitals because you know my time is
free during the week and on the weekends
i travel and that's something that
that's time that you can never ever get
back you can't continue to acquire you
know trophies and mvps and put up
records but at the end of the day you
can't replace that time with your kids
and your family yeah i agree but you
know he's wired differently and you know
you've been doing this for just 30 years
it's a sacrifice dan if you want to
invest more time into your job then
guess what you're going to feel it on
the back end because your kids are going
to be like you know daddy daddy you had
everything and you missed this and you
couldn't make it to that and and when
you play on that level it's not just you
sacrificing your entire team your entire
family sacrifices your wife your kids a
lot of pressure goes on them because of
your dreams and your aspirations
uh thanks for joining us you had a great
season always great to talk to you and
uh have fun this spring and summer with
the kids
hey man i appreciate it i hate i
couldn't get over to your table i had a
group over at the um hotel and i saw you
over there and at the end i couldn't
even get over there to you it's okay
good to see you i didn't take it
personally although chris sims came over
and then uh tony dungy came over and
drew brees came over
i mean just my friends came over rod
yeah but they're not on they're not on
television with you right now at nine
o'clock oh okay all right that's fair
enough
that's fair enough uh thank you rod
love you dan take care buddy that's
rodney harrison nbc football night
america two-time super bowl champ